okay one more story having to do with
joe manchin killing the build back
better legislation this week we have to
talk about how the squad was actually
proven right and centrist democrats were
proven wrong at least when it comes to
one important aspect of all this a few
weeks ago when the physical
infrastructure deal was being debated
there were several members of congress
the progressive democrats specifically
who urged house speaker nancy pelosi and
senate majority leader chuck schumer to
couple the infrastructure deal with the
multi-trillion dollar spending bill
built back better and indeed for a few
weeks those two bills were coupled
together and the idea was that manchin
and some of these other centrist
democrats they're sure yeses on physical
infrastructure they definitely want to
see that get passed but when it comes to
the multi-trillion dollar spending plan
we just can't trust them they they seem
to be changing their minds and you know
we just don't know if they're sure yeses
eventually nancy pelosi decided to cave
to the moderates in the party and uh
they decided to separate the two bills
and biden gave her the stamp of approval
to do so saying that we're going to be
able to assure that joe manchin is going
to vote yes on both pieces of
legislation so
joe biden he essentially gave us his
word on that but the squad they weren't
buying it so when it came time to
actually vote on the infrastructure deal
in november most of the congressional
progressive caucus they decided to vote
yes that's pramila jayapal katie porter
rokhana and a bunch of other familiar
names but the squid the six squad
members they held firm and they voted no
that's jamal bowman corey bush
alexandria ocasio-cortez ilhan omar
ayana presley and rashida talib and they
voted no not because they don't want to
see infrastructure get passed that's
actually quite the opposite they
definitely are in support of revamping
american infrastructure but they viewed
this as the best bargaining chip that
they had for making sure that both of
the bills got past the physical
infrastructure and the so-called human
infrastructure
and at the time there was a sentiment
among many democrats that was like look
let's get infrastructure done biden
hasn't had a significant legislative
achievement in a while maybe not since
the coveted stimulus plan was passed
back in march and we also don't know if
we're going to be able to in the long
term maintain this 60 vote threshold
that we need in the senate to get this
passed because you really can't trust
republicans like maybe they'll decide
they don't want to support this thing
anymore the idea was let's get it done
now we'll get this round of positive
press coverage about the infrastructure
deal and then before the end of the year
we'll get build back better done through
budget reconciliation and that will
prompt another round of positive media
coverage and it'll be viewed as yet
another accomplishment for joe biden and
the democrats obviously that didn't play
out and the squad was right to question
manchin's willingness to go along with
the rest of the party we actually have a
video now of camila jayapal talking to
many hassan about everything that went
on and she maintains that she has no
regrets in all of this but i i sort of
doubt that let's take a look at the
video and then we'll come back how do
you feel about that today do you feel
that joe biden let you down and do you
feel you got played by joe manchin
no and no um we are you know for the
weeks and the days going up to the vote
in the house everybody every day if i
had counted i would be if i got a penny
for every time somebody said to me this
is not going to happen you all have
given up everything we got it done in
the house now i am in the same place in
saying that we are getting grenades
rolled at us all the time we have to
pick them up we have to put the pin back
in and we have to continue to focus on
the fact that this is going to be rocky
we can't hang our you know our
commitments and our hopes on the words
of one senator or two senators we have
to continue to work to get it done and
the vast majority of it is done and so i
was on the phone with uh senator schumer
today with the white house and i believe
we will still get it done it's gonna be
rocky and we just have to continue to
leave no space in the um in the
commitment to getting it done and listen
the president's word is on the line here
and i do still believe that he is going
to do what he told me and what he told
our caucus and what he told the country
he would do
had we not done what we had done
and if he doesn't congresswoman
what was that
and if he doesn't
no we're gonna do it we're gonna do it
and the leverage that you had your
critics would argue was lost when you
voted for biff i just wonder do you
regret voting for the biff deal now in
hindsight given it's now months later
and joe manchin is nowhere closer to
signing off on 1.75 trillion
no i don't regret it because i i think
our leverage was at the maximum point on
the other side of the coin we have one
of the squad members aoc tweeting about
this saying quote when a handful of us
in the house warned this would happen if
democratic leaders gave manchin
everything he wanted first by moving
biff that's the bipartisan
infrastructure framework before build
back better instead of passing together
many ridiculed our position maybe
they'll believe us next time or maybe
people will just keep calling us naive
and unfortunately given the
establishment democrats track record on
all this and when it comes to them
trying to listen to progressives it'll
probably be the second one of those two
options there uh and they'll probably
just keep getting called naive but there
is a counter argument to all of this
that we have to consider as well and it
is a strong one which is that even if
the entire progressive caucus held firm
and they prevented the infrastructure
deal from getting passed in the house
and they made sure that it was only
going to happen in one piece of
legislation the two bills had to be put
together and that was it are we sure
that joe manchin would have actually
voted for it like the argument is that
he would right because he supports the
infrastructure deal and west virginia
desperately needs new infrastructure but
he just as easily could have done the
same exact thing here he could have said
you know i like some pieces of this
legislation i like the infrastructure
stuff but there are members of my party
who are trying to poison pill it with
all this other nonsense and there was
this opportunity to make this bill
bipartisan and the progressives are
ruining that opportunity so i just can't
support this bill in any form that also
could have happened that also is a
legitimate possibility and then
progressives at the end of the day they
look bad because they are the ones who
are blamed for not allowing
infrastructure to pass when even some
centrist republicans are willing to do
it and you have the remainder of the
democratic party in support of it so
what we know for now is that the squad
was definitely right not to trust joe
manchin not to trust his word because
his word means nothing but whether or
not we actually would have been able to
get both of these things passed by the
end of the year that remains uncertain
and to be honest i guess we'll never
truly know it's sort of unfalsifiable in
a sense because it really just comes
down to what joe manchin is thinking on
any particular day and that's
unfortunately what we have to deal with
so that's everything having to do with
buildback better as of now we're going
to go to a break back after this